con la esperanza de encontrar a un
personas con vida debajo de los
escombros ya casi totalmente perdida y
los equipos de rescate ya marchándose
del país sobre todo los Internacionales
los esfuerzos ahora mismo en Turquía se
centran en saber qué pasará con las
ciudades afectadas en todo el sureste
del país también lo han sido en el
noroeste de Siria ahora mismo equipos
del Ministerio de urbanismo turcos están
dirigiendo esta región para mirar uno a
uno todos los edificios que quedan en
pie en estas ciudades por ejemplo ahora
mismo en la ciudad de Alejandrita varios
equipos están dando vueltas por toda la
ciudad investigando los edificios y sus
daños según nos comentaban desde el
Ministerio están los agentes están
viajando esa región con tabletas con un
mapa interactivo de la ciudad en la que
apuntanse un edificio después de entrar
e investigar su interior Esta es
habitable aún o ya es imposible evitar
según esos daños que pueda tener ahí
vemos a mis espadas algunos edificios
con daños muy evidentes estos lo más que
se tengan que tirar en las próximas
semanas o meses sin embargo hay otros
que parecen por fuera
están en buen estado que sin embargo
podrían no serlo según nos explican
cuando entran en un edificio estos
inspectores del Ministerio de urbanismo
miran sobre todo la primera planta Y si
hay daños estructurales Y es que es
flechas en las paredes mesas de los
pisos de abajo si no las hay suben a las
prisas de arriba para comprobarlo ahí es
entonces donde aseguran si un edificio
es seguro para ser habitado o no